[Music]
Netflix enjoyed tremendous success this
year with its liveaction adaptation of
the anime series 1 piece the new
adaptation thrilled fans of the original
as well as new viewers next year the
streaming service will be responsible
for another liveaction adaptation namely
avatar The Last Airbender here in our
new original we give you all the latest
details on the plot the cast and the
production so stay
tuned currently it can be assumed that
the adaptation will be based on the
anime in avatar The Last Airbender we
are presented with a fictional world
that is split into four nations and is
otherwise based on historical East Asia
the nations are populated by people who
have mastered the bending of one of the
four elements and can use them in battle
the so-called Avatar can control all
elements and thus keep the various
powers in Balance however he is
considered missing and so the Fire
Nation involves the remaining nations in
a war one day the siblings qara and Saka
find the young Avatar a in a block of
ice and free him at first he only knows
the art of airbending and so the three
must set out on a dangerous Journey the
still quite naive a must learn to master
the remaining elements so that he can
stop the Fire Nation the first season of
the Netflix series could very well be
based on the first season of the anime
original and if successful also tell the
stories of the other Seasons the
original series consists of three
seasons with over 62 episodes the first
season of the new series is expected to
comprise Eight
Episodes the Avatar liveaction series
comes with a mostly unknown cast
11-year-old young actor Gordon Cormier
will play the role of Ang Cormier has
already won over audiences with the
series adaptation of Stephen King's
novel The Stand and is regarded as a
talented young actor Kio wio Tarbell
plays qara while her brother Saka is
played by Ian asley on the side of the
Fire Nation is actor Dallas Leu as
Prince Zuko who hunts down the Avatar
Fire Lord oai meanwhile is embodied by
Daniel Day Kim who had a role in the
remake of Hellboy Commander Xiao is
played by Ken Leong who some may
remember from Rush Hour the role of the
Cozy unco iro is played by son Yung Lee
while also appeared in the Star Wars
series Asoka and the Mandalorian as
Captain Carson Tava the role of aula
Zuko's mean sister is cast boldly the
character is played by newcomer
Elizabeth Yu who is celebrating her
debut with the series if Avatar proves
to be a success then questions will soon
arise as to who will portray the
earthbender Toff who will also be
joining the cast in the second season
and is considered an absolute fan
favorite but the cast so far already
gives fans plenty to discuss as to
whether the chosen actors fit the drawn
role
models Albert Kim who has already worked
as a producer on Sleepy Hollow will also
be involved in the Avatar series and
promised in an official press statement
that the new approach of avatar The Last
Airbender will be an authentic portrayal
of Asian and Indigenous characters he
also wanted to carefully transition the
animated series and deliver a
multifaceted new visual Dimension to
this fantastic world with the liveaction
series Roseanne leang who already worked
on the action film shadow in the cloud
with Khloe Grace morit will be among
those sitting in the director's chair
Swamp Thing veteran Michael and Game
of Thrones director Jabar Rani will also
be directing individual episodes for the
production Netflix teamed up with VFX
Studio pixoo they designed a stage that
is equipped with over 3,000 LED panels
and has a surface area of 23,000 s m the
same technology was already used in the
Mandalorian and its effects were
impressive the soundtrack is by Japanese
composer tesi furuk Kama who has already
provided music for a number of movies
and series including Star Wars the Clone
Wars despite much anticipation the
production is also viewed with skep iism
Mite shyamalan's first liveaction
adaptation 2010's The Last Airbender is
to this day considered a huge flop the
announcement that the creators of the
original series left the Netflix
production in 2020 as a result of
creative differences is likewise
unlikely to be a good
sign an official release date for the
Avatar The Last Airbender liveaction
series is not available yet still
Netflix announced during The Fan event
tudum that the series will debut in 2024
until then we look forward to more
insights into the project especially the
first trailer for The Avatar series what
are your thoughts on the adaptation of
the animated classic are you optimistic
about the project or do you foresee
another disaster let us know in the
[Music]
comments